welcome back there are some grim new
numbers for president biden when it
comes to the border
by a stark 46 to 15 margin voters in a
new fox poll say border security is
worse today than it was two years ago
all this as smugglers have been caught
in a new video now using a rope to lower
a mother and her kids down a 30-foot
section of border wall
meantime vice president harris coming up
with this excuse
when pressed on why she hasn't visited
the southern border it's been a month
since president biden made her the point
person for the u.s response to a record
surge in migrants
watch yes we're working on the plan to
get there we have to deal with covet
issues but
i can't get there soon enough in terms
of personally getting there
joe concha we have to deal with a covid
issue now that's a different story than
even that she campaigned on remember
where she made a focal point of that
campaign quote
making meaningful change to immigration
and their illegal immigration so what
happened to her pet passion
that's a very good question emily i also
want to know she's
fully vaccinated the vice president is
right and doesn't the cdc say it's okay
to travel when you're fully vaccinated
it hasn't stopped her she's gone to
something like
eight or nine other states texas for
whatever reason not on
that particular schedule so that excuse
is out and by the way in that poll
who are these 15 percent who think that
things are better
at the border who are these people to
quote jerry seinfeld
i mean so look if kamala harris ends up
being on the top of the democratic
ticket in 2024 and even some democrats
uh feel that that may be the case that
joe biden may be a one-term president
she's going to have to run on her record
as vice president this is her
number one priority right now and how do
you fix the problem when you don't see
the problem when you don't speak to
people
at the border and by the way why not do
a press conference once in a while
instead of that t-ball session that she
did
on cnn yesterday and i always hear this
excuse well vice presidents don't hold
press conferences that's funny i'm old
enough to remember uh 2020 when i would
see mike pence
on my screen at the podium that kaley
will be at in the james s brady briefing
room
taking questions for extended periods of
time when he was put in charge of the
corona
virus task force so for kamala harris
this could be her signature failure and
it could really hurt her chances in 2024
if joe biden decides that
in his early 80s he doesn't want to run
for president again
so kennedy taking that a step further i
think it's clear that we're seeing a
strategy of protection however by the
democratic party because now remember
anytime we address or the press
addresses her new role with the border
she says no no
remember it's only about the northern
triangle no no it's about finding the
root causes there is a
clear chasm between what they're
charging her with
and where that festering mess is
happening i think so that she can keep
her record clean
your thoughts yeah the the auth the
ostrich technique
is not working it is simply not working
to pretend
that the surge at the border isn't
having a horrible effect on children and
families
it is uh there is so much confusion and
the only signaling from this
administration is
if you send your kids a loan if you sell
everything you've got and send your kids
with smugglers when they get to the us
we're not going to send them back
that that makes these kids pawns in this
entire enterprise
and puts them at so much risk and her
list of excuses
i don't even think she understands what
word she's using when she says i can't
get there soon enough well soon enough
is now
now is when the surge is happening and
the surge is only going to get worse and
worse
so go fix it now you can absolutely work
on those root causes but go down there
get affected by it get angry get
emotional
see what's happening with these kids and
then do something about it because she's
been put in charge
and she's not gonna be on spirit hair
you know to joe's point she's fully
vaccinated
she will fly a plane with like four
other people
she's like the john kerry of vice
presidents oh yes
we're gonna talk about him later
[Laughter]
kaylee uh kennedy mentions um the
children are being used as pawns and
we've heard the absolute
horror and atrocities that they have to
go through to even get to this country
and let alone then
be packed in like sardines uh
instructions and whatnot and however
they're being given
a book everyone is being given a copy
apparently of vice president kamala
harris's book and my question to you is
would there be
any of the acceptance of this that there
would that there is now if this had been
happening under the prior administration
and what are your thoughts
on these kids getting superheroes are
everywhere
yeah one of the lines in that book that
these children are receiving is in times
of trouble superheroes always show up
uh well the superhero kamala harris has
not shown up
for the 14 to 17 year old girls in a
migrant facility in houston
that had to be shut down because they
were having to use the bathroom in
bags and they were not allowed to stand
up from their beds uh the superhero
didn't show up for them the superhero
didn't show up for the four and
five-year-old who was tossed by smuggler
over a 14-foot wall superhero didn't
show up superhero didn't show up
for the kids who are victims of violence
60 percent who are victims of violence
as they make that dangerous journey
uh superheroes not showing up because of
covid she says
uh what a lame excuse i've been on the
vice president's plane it's perfectly
safe for her to go down there
and even if you put aside the fact that
she's vaccinated we've talked about on
this panel
our frontline workers didn't stop
working during the pandemic our
healthcare workers our police officers
did not
why is it fair for the highest office in
the land our elected officials
not to show up it is an excuse and it is
quite sad
because she doesn't know what to do
if you don't have the answer you can't
rush to the border
what are you rushing for i mean that
that's got to be part of the calculation
here
and if they want to fill in the gaps
take a news conference let us ask some
questions and you can tell us what the
truth is
right be transparent communicate but to
kaylie's point the question the vice
president asked it herself
vice president harris where are these
kids superhero
for now she is m.i.a